>> Tucker: WHEN THIS COUNTRY IT
AT ITS WEAKEST BARACK OBAMA
APPEARS OUT OF NOWHERE TO MAKE
THE COUNTRY WEAKER AND MORE
DIVIDED.
THIS WEEK OBAMA APPEARED TO
TELEVISION TO TELL US ANYONE WHO
CLAIMS THAT CHILDREN ARE TAUGHT
IN SCHOOLS THAT SOME RACES ARE
BETTER THAN THAN OTHERS.
IS A BIGOT.
THERE IS A HOSTILITY AT THE
BOTTOM OF BARACK OBAMA.
GLENN BECK IS ONE OF THE FEW
PEOPLE WHO SAW IT FROM THE
BEGINNING.
HE IS THE HOST OF THE GLENN BECK
RADIO PROGRAM.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
YOU HAD A CLEAR PICTURE OF WHO
OBAMA WAS UNDERNEATH.
YOU FELT THE HOSTILITY
UNDERNEATH HIM.
THAT WAS A DEEP INSIGHT BACK
THEN.
>> BACK THEN, TUCKER, YOU COULD
NOT CALL A PRESIDENT RACIST.
BACK THEN THAT WAS CRAZY.
NOW THAT WE HAVE GONE THROUGH
THE TRUMP ERA, IT'S OKAY.
HERE'S THE THING.
I APOLOGIZED FOR SAYING THAT
ABOUT 2 YEARS LATER BECAUSE IT
WAS UNARTFUL.
I WAS THINKING OUT LOUD.
I WAS ON FOX AND FRIENDS AND I
SAID I THINK THE PRESIDENT IS A
RACIST.
NO, THAT'S NOT QUITE RIGHT.
I THINK HE HAS A PROBLEM WITH
THE WHITE CULTURE.
HOLY COW, WHAT DO YOU MEAN BY
WHITE CULTURE?
I DON'T KNOW MARXISTS, TELL ME
WHAT YOU MEAN BY WHITE CULTURE.
I WAS NOT VERSED ON CRITICAL
RACE THEORY IN THE LANGUAGE OF
MAXISTS.
NOW BARACK OBAMA I AM.
I TAKE MY APOG BACK.
-- YOU ARE A RACIST.
IF YOU BELIEVE IN CRITICAL RACE
THREY AND THINK WHAT DR. MARTIN
LUTHER KING SAID THAT HE
ENVISIONS A COUNTRY THAT IS
SEEING PEOPLE FOR THE CON10 OF
THEIR CHARACTER AND NOT THEIR
COLOR, YOU IF THINK THAT'S WRONG
YOU ARE A RACIST.
-- IF YOU BELIEVE THAT CRITICAL
RACE THEORY TEACHES CHILDREN
THAT WHITES AN INCURABLE DISEASE
AND YOU WILL NEVER NOT BE
RACIST, THAT YOU HAVE TO BE
CHARGED FOR THE SINS OF THE
PASS, I DON'T BELIEVE IN THAT.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT AND I DON'T
BELIEVE IN COLLECTIVE SALVATION
WHEN YOU DO.
YOU REJECTED WRIGHT.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THE NEW
SENATOR IN GEORGIA?
I BET YOU LOVE HIM.
BUT I BET YOU DON'T HAVE THE
COURAGE TO STAY SAY IT.
-->> Tucker: THERE IS
A HOSTILITY AND ANGER THERE AND
MEANNESS UNDERNEATH OBAMA.
I COULD ALWAYS FEEL IT.
IT'S VERY OBVIOUS NOW.
I AM SURE YOU SAYING THIS OUT
LOUD WILL BRING ANOTHER TIDAL
WAVE OF RAGE.
IT'S BECAUSE YOU ARE TELLING THE
TRUTH.
>> I AM TIRED OF TOWING THE
LINE.
I AM TIRED OF THE MARXISTS.
I WAS CALLED A RACIST FOR
CALLING HIM A MARXIST.
HE IS A MARXIST.
IF YOU BELIEVE IN CRITICAL RACE
THEORY THERE IS NO SCIENCE
BEHIND IT.
IT'S A MARXIST THEORY.
MEANT TO DIVIDE PEOPLE AND
DESTROY A COUNTRY.
WHAT ARE WE DOING?
HIS WIFE EVEN SAID BARACK OBAMA
KNOWS WE HAVE TO CHANGE YOUR
LANGUAGE AND CHANGE OUR
TRADITIONS.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE ARE
DOING.
HE SAID THIS WEEK THAT JOE BIDEN
IS JUST FINISHING THE JOB HE
STARTED.
HA JOB IS THE FUNDAMENTAL
TRANSFORMATION OF AMERICA.
BARACK OBAMA SAID IT'S ALL ABOUT
THE ECONOMY.
THEY ARE THINKING ABOUT LOSING
THEIR POSITION.
I DON'T CARE.
I WANT MY CHILDREN TO HAVE
FREEDOM.
I WANT MY CHILDREN TO MAKE
A CHOICE ON WHAT THEY DO.
HOW THEY LIVE.
WHERE THEY LIVE.
I WILL NOT BE SILENCED BY
A BUNCH OF MARXISTS.
AND BARACK OBAMA, YOU DON'T HAVE
THE COURAGE -- YOU TOO MUCH
HILLARY CLINTON IN YOU.
THAT'S WHY PEOPLE DIDN'T LIKE
YOU THE SECOND TERM.
HILLARY CLINTON JUST PUT YOU
DOWN A CHUTE.
>> Tucker: THANK YOU F